we're always looking for stories that
are character driven we're always drawn
to some sort of Journey that a person or
a group of people or in this case
something was going on
for good night Opie the first archival
that we ever watched was Opie's funeral
it's when the final wake-up song was
played and I remember watching that
footage and being so shocked with the
amount of emotion that was in that room
and I knew we had something special in
just watching that footage and so it was
from there that was going to be the
ending of our film how do we build
backwards what led up to this moment
that all these people in a room are
crying over saying goodbye to a robot
[Music]
good night Opie is the story of a Rover
that was sent to Mars and was expected
to live for 90 days but live for 15
years and it's a story of a bunch of
people who came together from all over
the world to do something really
remarkable this time we'd like to invite
you to sit back and enjoy the landing I
think the draw to the movie at the
beginning was the adventure story we
couldn't have written it more perfectly
into a script and when you're thinking
about any movie and you're thinking
about a protagonist's journey you want
challenges to that Rover and all of the
variables were unpredictable but then
what was interesting to us is really
getting to know the people if this
Landing didn't succeed this might be the
end of NASA in the back of your mind
you're like this could be a complete
disaster I think the beauty of
documentary filmmaking is allowing an
audience to be in the room to experience
what someone's experiencing as it's
unfolding they're on Mars everybody
looks like nothing I've ever seen before
in my life I got no words for this we
wanted to make this film where the
audience feels like they are there in
1998 and take the audience through
present tense through this story step
number one is research and so just did
dozens of pre-interviews with people
that played various roles in this
mission
what was interesting about good night
Opie is that we were coming into these
people's lives a year after opportunity
had died people at Nasa do not get a
grieving period for a robot they are
moved very quickly on to the next
mission and so we were knocking on these
people's doors a year later and they for
the first time in a year were talking
about their baby on Mars it was hard to
say goodbye I devoted 16 years of my
life to these Rovers what we thought was
going to be the biggest challenge ended
up being the complete opposite I had
this preconceived notion that scientists
and Engineers particularly at the level
that these people are working would all
be very academic and rational and black
and white and present the story that way
but none of them did all of them brought
so much emotion to their experience and
so much love for their work and
therefore also for this robot and each
other ladies and gentlemen are a
privileged to be in one of the most
exciting rooms on Earth at the moment we
knew that it would come through on
camera the biggest challenge in the end
was in a 100 minute documentary you can
only have a certain amount of voices in
it and this is a team of thousands of
people we picked 11 people in the end
and we use their anecdotes their
emotional connections to this robot we
were very careful about choosing human
beings that were from a wide breadth of
Life aerospace engineering wasn't
something that girls around me did I
didn't really know what that job was and
I knew they were the engineer but I
didn't know what that was I just knew
that I wanted to be the person that
always fixed things we wanted kids to be
able to watch this film who maybe don't
think that becoming a NASA scientist or
engineer is a viable path for them to
see their faces represented in the film
and then the question was how do we tell
the Mars portion of the story in a way
that's never been done before
each Rover had nine cameras on her so
there's hundreds of thousands of
photographs from each of their Journeys
so we know exactly what Mars looks like
so that was the beginning of our
conversations with ilm and they created
Mars from the ground up this is a
documentary way of doing visual effects
the very first thing they started doing
was creating the Rover itself using the
3D models that NASA gave them and that
Rover you know is real down to the solar
panel and I think they take a lot of
pride in the finished product because of
how photoreal it is because of the
visual effects we didn't have the luxury
like we normally do in a documentary
where you are finding the story in the
edit room ilm told us we can create
these effects for you but it's going to
take over a year so what do you want we
can create anything but tell us what are
those seeings that you want us just
start the ball rolling on
and so this is the first film that we've
ever written a screenplay for we used
the dozens of pre-interviews that Jess
did with scientists and engineers and
found the moments that were percolating
up over and over people would tell the
same story of opportunity getting stuck
in quicksand or Spirit not calling home
on Soul 18 and so we started to figure
out what those scenes that were most
important to people were and we wrote it
into a screenplay and then it was in the
archival footage that we were really
able to do the more traditional
documentary route where we find the
story in the edit room
foreign
access which was amazing it's almost a
thousand hours we had to digitize a lot
of material because it was just tapes
sitting on shelves and it was a big
project but it was it was also a fun
project it's like a you know an Easter
egg hunt you're finding those little
moments in all of that material they
don't come with labels saying there's an
amazing moment on this tape it had to be
watched down second by second and
someone had to find a needle and a
haystack for every scene that's in this
film
one of the best discoveries was called
the analyst notebook it's what Angela
Bassett ends up reading in our film
opportunity Saul ate we've gotten down
the first images of the Soleil right in
front of the Rover it's the strangest
looking thing we've ever seen on Mars
it's scientists and Engineers writing
down every day what they were
experiencing on the mission as
storytellers that are trying to keep
your audience on a day-to-day Journey
that's an incredible narrative device to
have and liftoff Blake Neely is our long
time collaborator he's often writing
music before we've ever shot a frame of
film
[Music]
with this film specifically we thought
Blake was going to have to shoulder a
lot of the Sci-Fi part of the film but
then once we hired Martin angeni our
sound designer who literally won the
Oscar for Dune while we were making this
film then Mark was able to go out to the
jet propulsion laboratory and record the
test beds of these Rovers so he was able
to get all real sound of what these
Rovers operating on the Martian terrain
sound like once we had Mark designing
all of that authentic sound it freed
Blake up to lean more cinematic
foreign
[Music]
I think we have the best job in the
entire world because we get to live
vicariously through these other people's
Journeys all the drama all of the
suspense all of the discovery in our
film comes because the human beings are
doing that themselves Through The Eyes
of this Rover I think it's rare as
documentary filmmakers to get presented
a hopeful story where people from all
over the world come together for a
common Endeavor that is so selfless like
a well-oiled machine isn't it I think
that there's also a great impact for
kids because the next Generation comes
in and then another generation comes in
and so I think that the missions Legacy
will be an inspiration and a building
block for the future
this is a story about the best parts of
humanity coming together to do something
amazing to not only pull off the mission
but Outlast the odds in the way that
they did it's pretty remarkable I'm
proud of this team and I'm proud of this
film because they were able to create
something beyond what we had expected
initially just like the scientists and
Engineers did
[Music]